you already know the vibes it's that
dawn dusty they're going hard
and yeah come roll with us son you know
the bootleg cat podcast
all right yo man it's the boule cavs
show we got a special guest in here my
god dusty locain
finally made it out to l.a man from the
floss to
to north hollywood you know what i'm
saying welcome bro
hey uh you know i got to go out to um
canarsie and
and and function with you and your
people um
i got to check out your neighborhood we
went to the studio went to the store we
did a lot that did
yeah man yeah a lot man you know
i've been telling a lot of people that
you really are sitting on some like
serious
records because i think the rolling and
controlling freestyle people it's like
it's a record that you're either gonna
love it or you ain't gonna rock with it
you know what i'm saying but you got
some big records that you were just
like that just you played me probably
like 20 songs and they were
i mean bruh salute is all i'm gonna say
once you start dropping i mean i know
you just dropped uh you you got two new
records out in the last
um moved doley yeah yeah yeah
yeah that record was dope i rolled in
the controller
but you got some joints you got some you
know what's crazy you never heard
rolling the controller
i didn't hear that song yeah i i
remember i make it
i ain't making it when i met you i made
that [ __ ] like probably about two weeks
before we dropped it
in atlanta so that's a fresh a fresh one
yeah so we saw that we broke the
whole order for that [ __ ] because what
well i want people to understand that
you could really make real records
like you know what i'm saying like you
got some records bro that uh
i mean it's gonna make the empire radio
staff their job extremely easy whenever
they come out
so that's what i'm saying let's keep it
like that um
how is it being in la i saw you wrote i
mean obviously for people who don't know
uh
rolling and controlling shout out to the
rolling 60s neighborhood rolling 66
allegedly allegedly allegedly
back with that allegedly you know that
yeah
but but you you actually came out here
and and tapped in with you know the
the origins of of of the role of 60s i
saw you know on the ig store you were
over there
uh yesterday shooting a video
[Applause]
how was that man that [ __ ] was
to be his life changing you know because
i was talking to that mic
let's get that mic right here you know
i've seen all this [ __ ] on like
youtube and um movies
but i ain't never been nowhere like that
like they really from the same [ __ ] just
a different
hood you see what i'm saying like it's
different city different states so
it was like me going in i felt right at
home like [ __ ]
they showed me love like i knew them all
my life
yeah i mean you're holding it you're
holding down the uh you know the
the set on the other side you're living
up one of the homies allegedly
you know what i'm saying shout out to
nip though man um
how was that though like because i think
a lot of people you know
la obviously you know the the origins of
a lot of gangs are here you know what
i'm saying and
and um did you always have like big
homies that were out here
or like before uh you know i only knew
the neighborhood [ __ ] from
east coast right you know but more or
less
through this rapping it tapped me in
with
well really let me be real you got to be
tapped in with somebody if you east
coast crippling
jacking the west coast you feel me sick
so i'm saying so
i heard of them feel me names was
brought up to me but i didn't get to
actually be around and [ __ ]
so that in itself for me was such a big
thing like for them to really take me in
with no problems
embracing you embrace me fully so i'm
saying like
so i felt like i said right at home home
away from home
that's amazing for people who don't know
you play basketball
um that was that that was your original
like dream was to to do the basketball
that was your original thing right how
far did you get
hooping um juco so junior college
junior college i only did like a
semester and a half
i was after that semester and a half and
then it was it was
was back to canarsie where'd you play
junior college at
um suny jefferson junior upstate upstate
new york
canada oh [ __ ] like 30 minutes from
toronto
so you was like right at the border yeah
did you ever go over to toronto [ __ ] oh
no
i heard it's hard to get into canada if
you if you're like i heard it's
it's it's easier to get into mexico than
it is to get into canada i heard they
don't [ __ ] around
at the canadian border yeah i i even i
didn't even go by you two was you're
telling me you got to go drive there i
have no call right so it's not like i
was referring me i was just like i heard
about it
30 minutes away [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
so once you left college came back to
your neighborhood
um what point in time i mean obviously
around that area your whole life but at
what point in time did you really start
to get kind of
active in the quote unquote you know
your area as far as you know
basketball's in your past you know well
like i said i was always jacking it even
before that
i was it like you know it was always
like i saw something that was in me not
only so
i jacked [ __ ] before i was cripp i walk
around with a flag around my head take
the train
all of that right right i was even on a
set feel me like
that was just it was just like i said it
was something it was just i
i [ __ ] through the heavy like i [ __ ]
with the with the whole
culture and i was from i'm from there so
it's like it was a no-brainer by the
time i turned like 17-18 it was like
for me we fully active now that area
that
that was kind of the area like that that
was where you grew up with was
was kind of that was the the section
that it was was essentially
that was around you anyway oh yeah yeah
i was already it wasn't like i could
have avoided it right right
i didn't go to no private no private
schools or i was in public schools you
for me and
i was in one of the one of the one of
the bad
high schools too at that public school
so film me
but um more or less yeah i'm a product
of my environment but i i flipped the
script
you know what i'm saying like not for
sure man you got to take
what they try to use to hold you back
and let it push you forward so
that's what i did that's what you're
doing man for people who don't know
how i mean when did you actually start
rapping
like it was in the pandemic right yeah
no no that's one
two words because i got locked in the
pandemic but like
i used to just boom like i said i had a
mess bandit
joker they was rappers from me right i
knew what i was doing my ones and tools
i was i was never a rapper i wasn't into
that but um
they were telling me you'll pull up fill
me i'll go smoke
cool it fill me bunny look at one two
jumps you drink a little
and after that i'll just be chilling and
then if they get tired
all right try some [ __ ] right got the
look you got the voice go do that [ __ ]
cuz
i'll try it but i never i never really
took to it you know
like it was just like that's just
something there ain't never
so i never put out a track i'll say
before
corona had about four tracks and like it
was mainly features and other ones was
just dumb [ __ ] like
one time i was mad drunk i just made a
freestyle
barely any worse these were online i
never dropped no food so they were just
on your phone
okay okay okay okay [ __ ] are being a
call head out the window
right it's the latest track but [ __ ]
always took to my [ __ ] because [ __ ]
know what i'm talking about
and for me that's really what it is so
but
i'll say when i really said yes it's
that time
it was like commander to waters came
home
right after that linked up with my boy
bob you know 6-0 and that was uh
roland controlling was that your first
official release
in fact my first official release and on
top of that
you know it was a real like from
beginning to one freestyle
all off the top of your head and the way
it happened like
it's just i heard the beat i'm thinking
myself this [ __ ] is crazy
right i told my mirrors running back put
down my phone right there put the
recorder down
went straight too that's crazy and at
that time
where like you know the p because at the
time you didn't have a following you
know what i'm saying what what
social media i'm saying what what
platform did that really start to heat
up on oh
let me that's a story too i never really
got to you know tell nobody but
when i first came home i got into a
little situation with someone you're not
going to say names but with some
i'll say not the other side but people
who was portraying to be the other side
okay
you i wanted to do something about it
but you know
now going today telling your chill cause
like yeah don't even go that route with
phil mutes
smart move so i went on to love
my man's love on facebook at the time
facebook yeah for me i i still had i
have no social media so i went on his
phone one of his [ __ ]
we live like a good i'll say about two
and a half hours being a telly
that night [ __ ] is all we just
chilling some [ __ ] was about to pull
up
so we only on the loves and then it just
started drinking like
at one point i had like 700 um viewers
and overall it had 32 000 at the end of
it
like on the facebook live on the
facebook live so people were saying like
oh
follow me oh foreign
like [ __ ] ain't never going to be the
first ones to gravitate especially now
it's always the women you're doing
of course of course they're going to
most likely hate them they're going to
be hated so
the females really that's my the females
and the kids
i would say is who i really look to and
appreciate the most
because [ __ ] be bandwagon they just oh
now the [ __ ] is all around him now we
got to be around him cause we want some
[ __ ] too like of course
tell me so it's like them two sex and
they're my [ __ ] of course but
anything outside of that i i show my
respects to the females the kids
feel me but um yeah it jinxed from there
it was like they said oh make it
instagram
make instagram making this i made it
june 27th
i still got the first i got in my art
challenge but you could see
it said you found me june 27th it was my
first post
so that was your first post and and what
day what day did you put rolling and
controlling out
oh no what day was that
late july wow that's crazy yeah and i
really have no i have faith in it
because
through you know like i said through
bobby
i was able to get signed but it wasn't
like
he knew i had it in me right i'm just
like i never do this before but i'm
going ahead i'm going head first like i
ain't thinking about nothing
in the back of my mind it's like damn
there's something new to me i i got high
hopes
so if this [ __ ] don't go the way i
expect it to go
it's not gonna break me it's gonna make
me go even harder but at the same time i
was like
this got to be it this has to be it what
was
bobby could probably answer this better
than you can but he's standing over here
but i'm curious because
at the time you had no music out you
just created an instagram account
so for someone like bobby fischer from
empire to step out and like
really see something in you like that's
that that that doesn't happen nowadays
often
it's it's easy to come in when
something's already on fire and pour
gasoline on it but it's harder it's
harder to start the fire
100 feel me so like i said that's
somebody who believed in me before
anybody else did around me he's seen it
fill me in like
that to me was the biggest the biggest
you know
things somebody could ever did for me i
was
pop broke and he had no breaches telling
the people in my people's crib
i was on my brother matter of fact when
i came over i went back to my people's
crib and [ __ ] but
you know what [ __ ] ain't had no real
options he gave me an option but i
presented myself as you know me
yeah he said i see that this is him you
heard me like
this who he is from the time you wake up
time to go to sleep
for me nothing changes about him so
like i said bobby that's doesn't mean
we're going to be together
well 6-0 yeah and you guys have i mean
he's i mean
you guys got i think that at the moment
you probably have a
a lot of generic fans who probably see
you on instagram who probably are
your naysayers i'd say who you know
because they they
you you got a few records out but i
think that oh yeah they don't know
they don't know what's coming but those
who not tuned you gotta tune them in
that's up to me yeah for sure everybody
else but me to say well look
i'm gonna show you what i'm made of and
what i'm capable of everything take time
though so that's why i ain't really
rushed nothing you can never say you've
seen me try to force it
for my waiting my turn through
everything i ever did in life i always
waited my turn that was a constant for
me
so when everybody was politicking
on instagram this he trying to be this
thing trying to do this
i was working see what i'm saying yeah
so when it did come to time now for
me to perform there was no there's no
flaws there
you know what i'm saying you got to make
sure when nobody's looking is when you
doing that
so when now they are looking there is no
denying it right right
right i think too a lot of people who
would be in your position because you
obviously get compared so much to pop
smoke who's
from your from your area you guys sold
you guys went to elementary school
together you guys are from the same hood
like i think that
a lot of people would run from that but
i feel like you've paid a lot of respect
and also have taken take on the
challenge
of saying yes you know maybe i was
inspired by pop
of course but at the same time i'm gonna
show you i'm my own dude
you know what i'm saying inspirations is
all around you and you should look to
them
as motivation nothing less nothing more
for me like
i watch other people betray you know
like
certain things like yeah we was this we
was that and no actually using that for
clout you're trying to get your own name
up based off another person now i'm
paying my respects
but through like i said my work ethic
and my drive you're gonna see how we
separate
how we differ yeah well but actually we
wanted the same
fill me floss a doll one way in no way
out [ __ ] know that there it is man
there yeah for people who don't know
your area canarsie is an area that
um is probably one of the least known
outside of new york you know we're in la
we're here in brooklyn we know what
brownsville is we know what
yeah but i feel like canarsie probably
has gotten the least amount
he was overlooked for a long time yeah
and we was doing we was the ones getting
most of the money
for me we was behind a lot of other [ __ ]
too but
you know [ __ ] kept that low profile
like i said pop brought us to the light
from me he said well look these [ __ ]
over here giving it up the same way
[ __ ] is over there
feel me and we just i'm just another
person who gonna prove that
um the the name the floss was that came
from a fabulous record right
i believe so fabulous i don't think he
said he said it in the line
like that op was my book yeah he told me
that he's the one who told us yeah i
ain't he's one of those i just know
floss is the floors cause that's what we
do yeah you know
that's what we do day in and day out for
me even before i was flossing
like this i was floating for me so it's
not really what's on you like i said
yeah yo it's crazy i had big you sitting
in that same chair and he said that he
said
it i don't got no tattoos and you know
big u
is a legendary figure in the streets you
know what i'm saying he said it's it's
it's in me it ain't on me that's why you
know what i'm saying that's some real
[ __ ]
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
oh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks
underwear the boxer briefs are the best
underwear that you could ever fit on
your ass trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 off of
of your order underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
heaven check out save 20
um what is next like i know you you
you're sitting on a lot of records
are we just doing the single thing for
now dropping singles
we're gonna keep it that way i told um
everybody life of a5 which is the album
name
it will be dropping what i said june
11th my c day
but yeah that's coming up but that's no
longer fairly we going
we're going to postpone that due to the
fact that every time we go in that
studio
some new [ __ ] and some [ __ ] that you
just
can't can't make up you just gotta beat
it to just know like damn
so the album is not coming out june 11th
anymore no no to let everybody know know
what it's not
so to be determined to be determined
you know it's crazy because i feel like
uh you're getting
uh better at your craft like people
don't realize you just started rapping
man this [ __ ] is crazy like for people
who don't know like man like there's
people who do this [ __ ] for 20 years and
won't even sniff
the level of success that you got off
your first record do you feel like every
time you you
it's almost like riding a bike you're
gonna get better every time you feel
like you're improving as an emcee
yeah most definitely i think you know
what it is like i said with everything
i'd invented
in my life overall it was always about
getting to newer heights basketball i
started out
the back of the line right by my 11th
senior grade year
as a star player everybody knew my name
in the school that was
that was just it was just like it was
always something i'm on
i can't fit in i got to stand up for
that you got to work
my work ethic and my determination stems
from basketball stems from sports i
played football too going up
but it stems from all of that because
you know you got to be disciplined yeah
most of themselves go to practice
yeah you know when maybe i was working
out day in and day out eating day in and
day out so
i was telling myself you know themselves
push-ups i'm not stopping
so my body can't stop not my mind you
want to tell your body to stop when you
could really keep going so i just
that's how i learned and that that works
with everything
that's not just for what you're doing
you got to take that outside of
everything you're doing and
use it in every walks of life so that's
what i try to do
how long were you locked up not long it
was i was remanded
okay it's a 72 hour hole but through the
corona that was lifted
they no longer so i was just in there
for me and they didn't allow me to post
my bail so my lawyer was just fighting
for motions motions motions
through me and i never really got in
them until is that is that are you are
you past whatever
situation i'm not really i really want
to be talking about this but
listen i know what it is i know what
it's like to have a [ __ ] case
floating over your head that should
if you think about it too much it'll get
it [ __ ] with you the only reason i don't
think about it because my understanding
that you know
you gotta whatever you do there's
repercussions behind it of course
and if you're not willing to accept
accept those you can't be called to men
grown men know that there's
repercussions and one day or the other
you may have to face those
um without getting too far deep into the
uh
politics of what's going on in brooklyn
you know there's a a very uh you know if
for people who've never even sniffed
brooklyn they know about the politics of
the streets that's going on between
we won't even say right but but there's
but there's a lot of um
it's spilled over into rap you know what
i'm saying there's rappers on both sides
people have gotten stabbed it's crazy
yeah 100 um
you're someone who obviously man you're
special you you have a star quality
um and there's there's been so many
artists that we've
lost over some [ __ ] right and you
know obviously in pop's case it
it wasn't it was out here it was a you
know it was it wasn't over
some [ __ ] from back home but but is that
something that you're very like
conscientious of when it comes to just
moving around because you never know
you know you might run into somebody at
brooklyn chop house or something
you know what i'm saying like my
paranoia is really what
keep me sane like me always being on
goal always watching my surroundings
it it put me in a place where i know i
well
if i was lackadaisical with this it's a
possibility this could happen but i'm
always going to be on it so nothing
could happen and then again there's
times that you was on it and something
happened
so then that's where the surrounding
right
group of [ __ ] come in you know your
gang your brothers
they got to be the ones to step on
[ __ ] next before they even get to
chance to get to a [ __ ] like me
i'm saying because you know what i stand
on when you see me you feel me i'm not
i'm not wish-washy the way you met me
that first time is the way you're gonna
meet me every time
so like i said people will know like oh
i well
feel me yeah this [ __ ] he got it
but then let's check and see who else
around him is on that [ __ ]
make sure everything is you know cope
aesthetic or what they say it is
i know your family's still in uh
canarsie i know you're still in canarsie
but at the same time i see you in miami
atlanta all the time have you considered
leaving new york
getting the voice get the [ __ ] out the
way is what i'm saying of course
of course it's it's it's it's emotion
miami's got to be the player i feel like
miami is just the women and the strip
clubs and the
no state tax and coronavirus never
existed there apparently you know what
i'm saying like
just gotta stay tuned to find out where
i'll go but right now i'm still in the
fifth what's your favorite city uh
outside miami i am in atlanta atlanta
something was
more like i'd say most of my biggest
tracks was i love atlanta man
what what's uh are you a strip club guy
like did you participate in in
strip clubs in both cities
okay what's your what's the spot in
miami that you like is your favorite
cause there's
there's the spot on what's the [ __ ]
booby trap on the river i need more i
just
this is how i feel right now about that
there's tootsies where you can get the
fried lobsters
yeah [ __ ] need to show more love
before i shout out
any strip club word to my mother okay
that's it well not one in anybody's
strip club i'll show love
that's fine tell me so yeah i ain't
getting no shout outs from those strip
clubs
oh boy but you participate activities
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
they're better than you know what i
can't stand even when new york was open
the strip clubs is oh it's all about
bartenders it's like the actual
strippers is kind of whatever
but the bartender's got all the
followers and [ __ ] and they ain't
getting naked
like why am i here there's a bunch of
sixes
that are the naked ones all the tens are
at the [ __ ] bars like
like what the hell is going on man
anyway yo when you when you hooked what
position did you play
a point guard shooting guard okay i
could
i was really a scorer but i know how to
you know he's
in the floors like brandon jennings or
some [ __ ] montana lsd
not monty i'll say yo so where's someone
zone out here
milly you was here derozan what you
would say who you think i used to play
like cuz
i was just overall like i said i
commanded the floor so
it was like when it was time to get a
bucket i'll turn that on
matter of fact i'm lying about my 12th
grade yeah i was just i was scoring
without
thinking oh i got charged yeah this is
my ball but
like i said i also always had it to
where i wanted everybody involved
got you that's what it and that's me
like yo it's crazy how basketball
translate cause we're look at me
it's real life [ __ ] yeah in any
situation
i'm never thinking about myself it's
impossible
it's crazy because uh we interviewed uh
chris brickley who's out in new york
he's the trainer he'll be training uh
you know james harden and
kyrie i'll be seeing that [ __ ] j cole
and [ __ ] but you know cole he trained
cole and cole went did his
his improv [ __ ] right he went to africa
and played
like once you're the rap [ __ ] is out of
here would you ever reconsider chasing
that dream again it's like you think
it's 60 on an off date
but where would you give people 60 at
because i mean
yeah put up 60 years not in the yeah
ain't no league player because ain't no
hooper
but you phobia i still i still go get a
bunch yeah
i saw the nets like warming up to your
record and [ __ ] like that had to be
crazy
yeah just said to me that something like
i watched kyrie play i watched james
harden
and then he caught the yam to it so it's
like yeah my [ __ ] give [ __ ] energy
boy were you hesitant to do a sequel to
rolling and controlling because
i feel like sometimes that could go it
wasn't played
yeah it could go the other way that's
why yeah like me i would have never
thought of that yeah
off rip because that to me is like this
corny has pocky like
did you feel me but it was naturally
made so it was no denying it like
and he kept saying it i'm like that's
pitching me rolling he kept saying
no it's rolling but i sorry we're gonna
put in parentheses
because i need [ __ ] to know that's
picture of me rolling do la through
california with some bad [ __ ] and
gang members
is that what you shot this week yeah
yeah okay or 260.
how many videos how many videos you
should you have you shot in l.a just
that one the other one
yeah yeah because my like i came down we
came down one
monday and shot it on wednesdays
yesterday that's crazy man
were you a f like the other uh biggest
alleged rolling 60 in hip-hop history is
is nipsy hustle right you know what i'm
saying
did you come up like [ __ ] with
nipsey's music because i mean i was on
the other side you know
i wasn't heavy on it but i [ __ ] with
nipsey of course like what he stood for
yeah so like the music naturally hearing
it correlated with who he is
i just you had to [ __ ] with the music
you know but him as a person more or
less is what i looked at like
damn like fellaini you you what you say
you stand on every time
without waving so i respect that yo
talk about the drill scene in new york
it's um it's crazy right now
and you know i feel like obviously
chicago started it uk had their way but
new york's got it right now um fully um
was that always like the type of like
when you because you know
me growing up as a hip-hop head i think
in new york i think a [ __ ]
boom bap lyrical rap [ __ ] or 50 cent g
unit you know what i'm saying
that's more relatable the first one i
really that's me like i i didn't
i was never so in tune with music but it
was always around me
right i never had like a specific person
i listened to on a regular but
you know soccer my people's growing up
uh
compa that's the [ __ ] i heard and then
on the you know you got the r and b
artists and [ __ ]
all right so like me like i said when it
comes to
real music in new york it has
hints of what was in the past but it's a
whole
new wave right you know and it's and it
is like i said me i grab a lot of [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and put in my tracks you feel me
i grab a lot of whole [ __ ] put in my
tracks just
just you know the idea of it is cool
because you're still paying homage
who would you consider kind of like the
godfather of the drill [ __ ] in new york
i think pop smoke was the biggest but i
think he was the biggest but
i mean i think obviously obviously shout
out to fabi i think favi's one of those
guys
i'll say i'll say pop pop he he put it
on the biggest stage oh 100
to me it's like that's what a godfather
is you know i mean
everybody else here it was underneath
you but you was up there
well i think what he was able to do
unfortunately he didn't get to see the
uh
success of the sonic
chances he took on his new album because
he changed up his you know
he made some records that he made a lot
of i mean there was barely any drill
records on that album
and unfortunately you know he didn't get
to see that it paid off
but i heard a lot of your records that
you're sitting on and you got some of
them ones
so you know like you know oh and and
another thing that a lot of people don't
really know is
you know pop he started out you already
know drill he could
for me me too but i was really more of a
melodic from the jump like
i used to sing growing up so before my
voice got the rise spinning you know
and the bass and it was i was a singer i
could just sing my eyes
where would you sing like church or like
yeah i sing at church
i sing anywhere same way when wherever i
am at
it's a possibility you're gonna see me
performing you're gonna hear me singing
something
right rapping something cause that was
just my nature so
for me it was easier for me to do those
lovey-dovey tracks when it came time
right right right
right because that was kind of already
you're back
so it was nothing would you uh ever try
to infuse some of the caribbean
[ __ ] you came up listening to in your
household and do your music
even yeah surprised about track you
could hear the accent
on certain words but i'm gonna make a
whole wait i would say um
what you need what you need is the vibe
of it is a caribbean right
right you know he ain't hearing young
blue on that
and there's some caribbean vibes on it
ladies and gentlemen oh [ __ ] with that
that's a crazy intro right there there
it is coming soon
i'm going to see i'm supposed to see
blue this week so i'm going to ask him
about it
i heard you yeah i got one you know
outside of
outside of blue who else i mean you know
who else do you want to work with that
you haven't worked with yet
um everybody like i said before i [ __ ]
with all my son
who shines these [ __ ] little baby all of
them gonna
um what about it give me a new a new
york og if you could pick a new york og
any one of them to work with who would
it be
i don't know because i'll say it gotta
be jay-z
guys how it gotta be just off the street
nikki if you do the video at least you
know you you you might could
you know catch uh maybe catch catch a
nip slip or something on set you know
what i'm saying
maybe fab because he shouted out
quinarsi before you know what i'm saying
hey hope shout out you know what i mean
yeah that man well listen you're on your
way bro uh and
i know a lot of people are gonna be in
the comments and and they're gonna get
extremely uh
they you're gonna get the pop smoke [ __ ]
in the comments but i i want to make
sure that we did not talk about that and
i'm sure that that's gonna be
appreciated everything that there's
always love to the cubs regardless of
course but you know i i just
i think people got to understand who you
are you know what i'm saying and what
you do and what you bring to the table
and
and you know i think that they're you
got once these other records start
coming out
they're gonna get the picture they're
gonna get it man and plus you're playing
you're paying homage to to to the homie
as well
so it's all love man dusty locain
perfect